you're looking at America's latest
spying eye in the sky but have no fear
NSA isn't at the controls this is the
latest highest tech weather satellite
from NOAA called ghost 16 compared to
its predecessor it has three times the
spectral channels and four times the
resolution all with five times the
efficiency this thing can see everything
sulfur dioxide emissions from volcanoes
melting snow packs and I can even
distinguish between fog and clouds hell
I can't even distinguish between fog and
clouds half the time
ghost 16 can scan the United States in
five minutes and the whole planet in 15
perhaps most pressingly it can detect
flashes of lightning across the Western
Hemisphere lightning you see is a
dependable early warning sign of severe
weather including tornadoes all told
ghost 16 is a supremely powerful tool
for NOAA to predict weather of any kind
that's particularly important on a
planet whose climate is descending into
turmoil scientists need to closely
monitor weather to understand how the
planet is evolving and how cutting
carbon emissions plays into that weather
is getting weirder that's for sure but
the trusty goes 16 will be up above
helping scientists make sense of all
oh and making sure you know when to wear
your galoshes